ce réservoir principal de l'asm située à
rivière blanche de 8000 mètres cubes ne
contient que 10 cm d'eau une situation
qui se répète dans de nombreux châteaux
d'eau situés dans les quartiers en
hauteur des communes du centre et du sud
de l'île en cause une sécheresse
historique depuis plus d'un mois des
principales rivières de captage en
martinique sécheresse du carême
extrêmement sec qui fait que les
rivières sont très basses et nous
n'avons pas assez d'eau brute pour
pouvoir fabriquer d'eau potable le
déficit représente 40 % c'est énorme
vous imaginez ça représente 6 millions
de litres d'eau par jour qui nous manque
on ne peut pas donner l'eau que nous
n'avons pas pour pallier ce déficit
important les opérateurs d'eau potable
au dc sm ont mis en place des coupures
tournantes
par zone géographique afin de faire
jouer la solidarité tout en insistant
sur les gestes citoyens
en ces temps de crise devant la
situation on n'a qu'à penser que seuls
les gestes solidaires
peppermint candy sorti qu'au nom il faut
nous doucher que non moins longtemps
il faut nous pas lavés l'automne où il
faut nous pas rempli des piscines
gonflables parce que nous nous pauvres
parce que c'est normal on est démuni
confiné il faut véritablement noni des
gestes citoyens
si nous les soit icônes ou d une autre
solution existe et elle consisterait à
mieux répartir les ressources
disponibles en eau potable dans le nord
de l'île nous avons suffisamment d'eau
sur le nord atlantique mais nous
n'arrivons pas à le faire descendre vers
le centre et vers le sud du fait d'une
canalisation qui est toujours provisoire
depuis dix ans et nous n'arrêtons pas de
le dire et de le répéter il est urgent
de restaurer la capacité
c'est une conduite de 800 mm de diamètre
vous imaginez qui aujourd'hui remplacée
par trois tuyaux de petite section
donc aujourd'hui cette canalisation
aurait été en place nous n'aurions aucun
manque d'eau nous nous sommes rendus sur
place aux lorrains et nous avons pu
observer ces fameuses canalisations
d'eau de la rivière
d'après les opérateurs d'eau potable ces
tuyaux n'aurait jamais été utilisée il
serait disponible sur le site depuis
plus de dix ans et nathan drake une
seule chose la mise en service